ÇWir sprechen Ÿber ein Buch.È
ÇDas Buch heisst ÜFrau SeinÝ.È
ÇEin Nachdenken, wie man sich
von seiner Herkunft freimacht.È
ÇIch wŸrde es einfach
schlichter ausdrucken.È
ÇFŸr einmal mšchte er
es schlichter ausdrŸcken.È
ÇJa, fŸr einmal. Und dann
werde ich unterbrochen.
Es ist ein Buch, wo es darum geht,
dass man sich von den Blicken der anderen
und den Erwartungen der anderen lšst
und sich selbst die Frage stellt:
Wo will ich eigentlich hin im Leben?
ÇDas finde ich jetzt gut.È
ÇIch habe mir MŸhe gegeben.È
ÇÜVon den Blicken der anderenÝ
ist insofern auch sehr schšn gewŠhlt:
Das Ganze wird ausgelšst
durch einen sogenannten Augeninfarkt,
und das setzt diesen ganzen Gedankenfluss
in Gang: ÜWo komme ich her?Ý.
Sie ist die Tochter von kurdischen
Gastarbeitern in Deutschland
und macht dann aber Abitur
und fŠngt an zu schreiben.
Es erzŠhlt auch von zwei Kulturen.È
ÇIch finde, was dieses Buch auszeichnet, ist,
dass es immer mit der TotalitŠt des Lebens
als Ganzes zu tun hat.
Dass es im Leben eben so ist,
dass es schreckliche und schšnen Sachen gibt.È
ÇAber es hat manchmal
auch wahnsinnig witzige Stellen drin.
Es gibt diese eine Szene, die ich sehr lustig finde,
aber natŸrlich auch erschreckend.
Die Mutter, die jahrelang geputzt hat im Amtsgericht.
Ein Richter hat ihr tŠglich ein Leberwurst-Brot
mit nach Hause gegeben,
damit sie ihre Kinder ernŠhren kann.
Sie wusste: ÜNatŸrlich kann ich
meine Kinder ernŠhren.Ý
Sie war aber nicht in der Lage,
das dem Richter zu sagen.
Und es ging sogar noch weiter.
Sie ist dann nach Hause gekommen
und hat gesagt: ÜAus Demut und aus Dankbarkeit
mŸsst ihr euch jetzt dieses Leberwurst-Brot teilen.Ý
Dann haben sie immer darum gekŠmpft,
wer am wenigstens essen musste
und haben das dann aufgeteilt.
Mely Kiyak schaut sich das jetzt an,
und macht sich frei von all diesem Ballast,
der ihr da mitgegeben wurde.È
ÇDas Ganze ist ja assoziativ.
Es ist ja so eine
Aneinanderreihung von Szenen.È
ÇDas ist auf eine Art sehr heterogen.
Es hat ganz, ganz viele verschiedene ZugŠnge.È
ÇIch finde schon, man muss auch Kritik
anbringen kšnnen, wenn man sie hat.
NatŸrlich ist es insofern Literatur,
als dass es quasi ein Textkšrper ist.È
ÇNein, nicht nur das. Es ist
ein Šsthetisch geformter, durchdachter...È
ÇDas ist der Unterschied
zwischen uns hier, Nicola.
Der einzige Faden ist quasi die Chronologie.
Ich finde es sehr reizend,
wenn man die TonalitŠt wechseln kann.
Aber ich stelle dann schon den Anspruch,
dass das einen Rahmen hat
und diesen Rahmen hat es nicht.È
ÇDoch ich finde schon, dass es den Rahmen hat.
Der rote Faden wŠre eben:
sich emanzipieren.
Aber ich glaube, in erster Linie
geht es wirklich darum:
Wie ist sie zu der Autorin
geworden, die sie ist?